(birds chirping)
(piano music)
- (speaks in foreign language)
(birds chirping)
(piano music)
- [Female Narrator] In Chennai, India,
there's a tiny camera repair shop
run by a man named Joseph Sekar.
- (speaks in foreign language)
- [Female Narrator]
Sekar got his nickname,
because everyday he feeds
thousands of hungry parakeets
on the roof of his home.
- [Joseph] (speaks in foreign language)
- [Female Narrator] The 2006 tsunami
that hit southeast Asia
flooded parts of India and
displaced thousands of birds.
Sekar noticed a pair of
parakeets outside of his home
and set some rice out for them.
Then more started to show up, and well...
- (speaks in foreign language)
- [Female Narrator] Feeding
eight thousand parakeets
twice a day is a great expense.
Sekar spends about 40%
of the money he makes
from repairing cameras
buying food for the birds.
- [Joseph] (speaks in foreign language)
- [Female Narrator] But
for the birdman of Chennai,
there is more to life than money.
- [Joseph] (speaks in foreign language)
(upbeat music)